mona bonjour vous êtes actuellement à
nanterre l'appel aux chanteurs ou des
appels à manifester dans toute la france
ont été lancés devant la mdph
ils sont un peu plus d'une cinquantaine
à s'être rassemblés pour défendre les
droits des personnes en situation de
handicap et vous l'avais dit il ya le
maquereau le président de la république
qui s'est exprimé lors de cette
conférence nationale du handicap il a
expliqué qu'il ne fallait pas annoncé
plus de loi il fallait seulement elle
les appliquer là également
à part les aides d'un numéro unique je
vous propose de l'écouter
toutes ces mesures surtout participe
d'une philosophie nouvelle où l'on ne
considère plus les personnes en
situation de handicap comme des figures
d'altérité au fond une extériorité eux
mais bien des citoyens à part entière
un numéro d'appel dédié aide handicap
école existe il répond à toutes les
questions des familles je leur donne
c'est le 0 800 730 123 nous devons
jamais nous habituer à ce que des
enfants en situation de handicap soit
privé en effet de la chance d'aller à
l'école de la joie d'apprendre du
bonheur de tisser des liens
pour moi le premier objectif c'est
qu'aucun enfant sans solution de
scolarisation ne puisse encore exister
au mois de septembre prochain et nous
avons pu parler à plusieurs personnes
lors de ce rassemblement il y avait des
profils assez différent à des personnes
en situation de handicap ou encore être
des associations et qui veulent moins de
discrimination surtout par rapport
notamment au logement ou encore à au
travail ou encore à l'éducation
également est également un sujet a été
abordé lors de sa discussion avec les
personnes que vous voyez juste derrière
moi il y aurait vraisemblablement un
tabou concernant l'assistance sexuelle
en france écoutez le pense sur le
handicap en france on accumule un
certain retard est en fait pour
aujourd'hui on pense que l'inclusion
c'est au travail c'est à l'école c'est
à l'entreprise mais on oublie que les
personnes handicapées peuvent être des
êtres humains ça je vous faire
comprendre une personne handicapée elle
a un droit de reproduction de vie
amoureuse de vie affective et ça c'est
quelque chose qu'on n'oublie pas ce
qu'on a tendance à mettre les personnes
handicapées dans des cases
on oublie qu'elles ont aussi une vie
chez elles avec leurs conjoints et pas
que voilà on parce que ça qu'on n'a pas
levé le budget pour assumer toutes
sortes de personnes handicapées avec la
hache
alors que s'il ya de moins en moins de
personnes qui touchent h au profit de
travail épanouissant et adapté c'est ça
que c'est pas n'importe quel travail je
veux que ça épanouissant et adapté et
ben là je pense qu'on y arriverait
beaucoup mieux pour arrêter de faire des
lois faut juste les appliquer ces tours
il ya une loi de 2005 et qui est sorti
pour l'inclusion des enfants au niveau
scolaire ce n'est pas appliquée le
président la république a fixé plusieurs
objectifs lors de cette conférence
nationale du handicap dont celui que
chaque enfants soient scolarisés dans de
bonnes conditions et notamment un sujet
que les enfants ou les parents ne
partent plus vers l'étranger pour
quitter la france faute de prise en
charge
ouanna hamoud en direct donc de la
maison des personnes en situation
d'handicap à nanterre merci pour toutes
ces précisions